sécurité des mines faisait vers ce qu'il
fasse beau qu'il fasse l'est c'est son
habitude plus qu'une habitude c'est même
son oeuvre depuis 23 ans tous les jours
sans exception
jacques jouet écrit un poème j'ai
commencé un 1er avril parce que ce
n'était pas très sérieux dans la tête
des gens je peux tenir deux mois trois
mois
et puis en fait ça fait 23 ans donc j'ai
23 ans et même maintenant je regrette de
pas avoir commencé plus tôt ça aurait
été alors je date le poème le localise
d'où je les écris dans la dans l'espace
de la journée je peux y toucher mais
après auger touche pas quand minuit a
sonné je n'ai pas le droit de revenir
dessus sécurité je lis quelque part la
sécurité des biens et des personnes dans
cet ordre la charrue est plus grosse que
le boeuf
l'arbre cache la forêt le cours en
bourse du bois cash l'arbre cache le
conducteur de la batteuse et branches
aux tronçonneuses forestière l'endroit
apporte peu le poème peut s'écrire
n'importe où par exemple sur un coin de
table chez mille univers maison
d'édition qui a publié certains les
livres de jacques jouet et qui
l'accueille à bourges pour une résidence
danon me l'univers c'est aussi un
atelier photographique qui permet une
impression immédiate des textes à peine
écrit est déjà mise en page et un prix 2
qu'est-ce qu'on pourrait le
vous pourrez décembre oui monsieur
pouvoir du plus mais c'est pour ça que
je fais une épreuve
alors là éventuellement un autre coup de
pied là sur le poteau est le dernier sur
le camion orange
vous les avez peut-être déjà croisé dans
les rues de bourges ou bien vous les
verrez un jour les poèmes de jacques
jouet ne sont pas forcément enfermés
dans des livres il leur arrive de
prendre l'air dans l'arc faut pas
l'attendre uniquement le livre de
librairie
inventer des situations de présence du
texte politique
la fiche on n'est pas nouveau mais mais
ça fait partie des choses qui j'ai envie
de faire mon père était un imbécile
ma mère était une abrutie mon grand-père
était en couille on se couper les ongles
avec un taille-crayon puisque les gens
ne vont pas forcément vers la poésie
contemporaine la poésie contemporaine
doit à l'état et pour ça on peut
l'affiché dans les rues on peut aussi la
mettre en musique dans le cadre d'un
spectacle pour enfants qu'on voit ici en
cours d'élaboration
et depuis deux ans jacques jouet utilise
une autre méthode
il adresse par la poste le poème du jour
au bond entier
j'ai commencéà avec cette idée de dons
d'adresser un peu m à tout le monde de
se taire j'ai commencé par le
département de l'ain je vous fais ça
c'est très organisé voilà je crois que
je prends le bottin des téléphones du
département de l'ain 01
et là je suis la troisième commune donc
chaque jour je passe un an ou
surligneurs là c'était normal il ya
énormément de choses à faire et à
couvrir les départements de la en plus
dense berruyères c'est aussi là
j'anticipe j'anticipe le département du
cher que normalement je devrais faire
dans trois siècles selon lui après il y
aura le gabon la grèce
tous les autres pays dans l'ordre
alphabétique à bourges les habitants des
rues verlaine et rimbaud ont déjà reçu
leurs poèmes ainsi que les résidents de
la maison de retraite bellevue assez peu
habitués aux travaux de l'oulipo
l'ouvroir de littérature potentielle
auquel appartient jacques jouet et dont
les membres les plus célèbres sont
raymond queneau georges perec des supply
l'auberge qui me fera est aussi sensible
il m'a ordonné dans la si belle campagne
boulonnaise
il vous sera facile de trouver le repos
d'oies blanches bien race me fermer en
effrayant et depuis elle celui bord
qu'un cap des jo a bruyamment et depuis
elle subit mort en moi les cris les
pleurs et des gémissements soutien
énergique à la poésie actuelle et comme
la peinture mais bon mais je trouve que
ça nous permet des échanges et des
rencontres déjà entre nous
voilà ça nous savons qu'ils apprécient
ou non cette littérature les résidents
de bellevue ont eu la chance de
participer en avril à un événement
unique
l'anniversaire unique du point du jour
ce n'est pas n'importe quelle date
aujourd'hui c'est le 1er avril le 1er
avril 1992 il y à 23 ans de cela et
c'est donc l'anniversaire aujourd'hui le
premier anniversaire de cette date
c'est un anniversaire que je souhaite
fêter tous les 23 ans et ils n'ont pas
tous les ans donc dans 23 ans je sais
pas si je serai encore là pour le
souhaitez mais peu importe vous le
souhaiterez pour moi je rentre à la
maison
même s'il n'a chef pas lui-même son
vaste projet jacques jouet désignera par
testament
les successeurs qui poursuivront son
oeuvre afin que les sept milliards deux
cent mille habitants de la terre
reçoivent leurs poèmes
surveillez bien votre boîte à lettres
bientôt peut-être une surprise vous a
plu